oh I laugh at even the insinuation that
you think you're better than me all Jack
slap the back of your ass out of your
head boy if you didn't think you can
come and get me well I mean I could put
up a fight if I you know actually stood
a chance against someone at 32 ah sir
how about we take this outside and then
settle it with fisticuffs like real men
would and then you'll say who's gonna
fight the best ever
ah you are the medicine with me ha ha ha
anyone see my guys anywhere they've gone
missing
I won't rush until I find them someone
you want to get a taste of these
luscious lips oh I bet you do
do you like my long neck and strong
jawline but you ain't never seen a
handsome fellow like this before in your
life
oh we have oh well don't mind me I'll be
on my ride I'll be out of your hair out
of my yard whatever the [ __ ] yourself at
lunch and says Bader you gotta listen
Bader it can't do these stupid reckless
things well gosh you this is the best
fix that I can get it for Bader the
wagashi oh ha ha ha ha doc give it to me
straight
how much longer do I have to live groans
stop what's that well it smells like
crime uh-huh say it to my face will you
go to prom with me huh you wanna mess
with me you want to mess with me buddy
you want to mess with these lips aah
laughs you're too young you don't think
I'll mess you up on huh yes I am
not a Gorgan I am having a human face
with man hands don't you see my human
ears and my human nose it is very good
for smelling human smells and especially
spelling north I love the smell of
beasts north in the morning oh hey
what's it over there
Oh looks so cute it's a good oh what is
that so bad good hey Jeremy come on in
here give me a hey give me a whole you
hey hey you behold did I hear that
someone was making fun of my shiny mouth
oh yeah she'd get people you see sorry
I'm sorry the four R's are as I did meet
you there after hogr got a flat iron I'm
here with my dog long dumb barb all
right chica what's wrong what's going on
chica are you disturbed by any of this
he was busy oh look at that smile
oh look at that award winning smile oh
no she probably no you look so grumpy
and sad or deaf not true right whoa
she's like you didn't touch her you
oh my god chica what happened to you
chica chica no chica oh my god Oh turned
into a tiny Pomeranian turned into a
bunny yes I love it when you blow on my
ear say hi to everybody
yay hi boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo
hi mommy
puppy I love you okay I'll let you go
now okay